kyle hendricks gets set to work against
this brewers lineup
this is adidas first career opening day
start sogard a left-handed batter waits
drives one in the air to left
playable for schwarber backpedaling over
near the line he'll make the catch
that's out number one
christian yellets now spring training
and summer camp combined
he was bad bounced back to the mound and
hendricks will make the play
cast in hero right-handed batting second
baseman
swing and a miss strike three hendricks
works one
two three the first inning is a breeze
brandon woodruff
getting his first opening day start yeah
i can't imagine he could have done any
better at
summer camps in the air right center
that's going to be lorenzo kane to make
the play and after a long battle
woodrow finally retires brian woodruff
walking rizzo the man is on with one
away and here's javier baez maya's on
the ground got a man there
could be two flip it rc into first in
time for the double play
kyle hendricks to face justin smoke
smoke appearing in his first game as a
milwaukee brewer
swaying in a minute strike three on a
beautiful changeup hendricks
picks up his second straight strikeout
swing and a miss
got him on the changeup three strikeouts
for hendricks third inning we go nothing
nothing game
omar narvaez a left-handed batting
catcher to face kyle hendricks
on the inside corner professor is
dealing strikeout number four swinging a
miss strike three
five out of eight strikeouts brewers
still looking for their first
base runner and the batter is orlando
arcia arcia into center field that's
gonna get down for a base hit
now the first hit of the season for the
brewers comes from their nine-hole
hitter
orlando arcia with a single this is
where the social distancing part gets a
little funky
i love it one ounce single for nico
horner
let's see if that leads to bigger and
better things no score
third inning one away ian happ the
batter half drives one in the air to
center back goes kane
kane's still going back still going back
that ball is gone
it's a two-run home run to setter for in
half
you had ian happen who hits the first
home run of the year pool you're a
winner
and the cubs lead two to nothing now
hendricks now has the lead for the first
time
and he'll face yelich hera and smoke
swing in a miss strike three hundreds
locked in tonight
kyle hendricks starting to rack up some
strikeouts that's number
six for hendrix so hendrix takes care of
yelich
now it's hira swing and a missed rank
three another
change up and another strikeout for kyle
hendricks
he has struck out four of the last six
batters he's faced in
seven punch outs overall batter is just
in smoke
strike three called on a fastball
strikes out the side he's a magician
tonight folks
kyle hendricks has allowed just one hit
through five shutout frames now
christian yelich coming up in a very
key moment in this game he's the tying
run in the sixth inning
swing and a missed strike three he got
him hendricks strikes out
yelich for the second time in the game
strikeout number nine for kyle as the
shutout is still intact and kyle
hendricks has been the star of the night
68 pitches through six full innings he's
allowed his two base hits to orlando
arcia
and he has struck out nine first pitch
to hira bouncer to third
bryant handles and throws out hera for
out number one
is he sweating i'm not sure if he's
sweating it's only been out of the
stretch to two batters that's it
seven consecutive innings now hendricks
has retired the lead off batter
fly ball right field shallow playable
hayward there
comes in grabs it out number two
a lot of routine outs behind kyle
hendricks he hits a bouncing ball to a
charging bryant short hops nicely
sets those feet and throws out braun
another one two three inning
for kyle hendricks he only threw five
pitches kyle hendricks a two hit shutout
now it's avi garcia to start it bouncer
back to the mound
should be an easy out number one it is
and that is
eight consecutive innings in which he
has retired the lead off batter in the
inning
the next pitch bouncing ball right side
in shallow right field glove by horner
long throw
in time two up two down in the brewer
eighth
hendricks is four outs away from a
shutout
kane hits a bouncing ball to short
grabbing it on the second hop is bias
and he throws him out
eight shutout innings in the book for
kyle hendricks
what a performance for him on opening
night here is anthony rizzo
you've got a 2-0 count two outs you're
up by two runs
why not look fastball and look to hit
one as far as you can hit it
rizzo drives one in the air deep right
field down the line curling in the
corner
that's going to be a home run so he was
thinking long ball
and that's exactly what he achieved the
cubs now lead three
to nothing kyle hendricks has pitched a
masterpiece thus far
and now there are two down that brings
david ross to the mountain with two outs
in the ninth at a three to nothing ball
game
i'm good he just wants to check in all
right
so hendricks against hiro and he hits
the ground ball to short this could do
it by us the second cubs win
it is a three-hit shutout for kyle
hendricks
as david ross is a winner
as a manager in his first game
of the chicago cubs but what a
performance by kyle
he goes the distance and beats the
brewers by a score
of three to nothing